[Musique]
bonjour breech parlant euh bonjour euh
je voulais vous demander euh
ce que vous pensiez de gec par rapport
à d'autres partages électriques
euh gc très solide pour le moment à l'air
très stable ils ont été stables ces
dernières semaines et euh je ne  Je ne vois pas la
situation changer une éventuelle euh
attention, je dirais que s'il y avait
des menaces de nationalisation à l'
horizon
oui
euh et pourquoi pensez-vous qu'ils ont de si
grandes réserves de liquidités,
c'est une question de savoir comment ils
vendent leurs actifs  et les utiliser pour
acquérir des actifs plus viables
achat et rachat professionnels ouais je vois
bien puis-je en acheter une centaine s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
cher premier ministre
ne pense pas que c'est une honte que
le glc gaspille l'argent des contribuables en
déclarations politiques dans la presse
je fais référence à l'annonce
sur les foires foire du 16 février
1982 au soir standard
ne croyez-vous pas aussi qu'il
faut changer la loi pour arrêter ce
gaspillage scandaleux de tarif  rs
argent car ces cas sont récurrents
euh fidèlement jacob rees-mogg
[Musique]
j'aime l'argent toujours les avoir
pourquoi parce que vous avez besoin d'argent euh et avec de l'
argent vous pouvez gagner plus d'argent
euh vous ne pouvez pas vivre sans argent vous
ne pouvez pas faire  n'importe quoi si vous n'avez pas d'
argent et si vous avez de l'argent,
vous pouvez acheter des choses acheter des choses que vous
voulez je pourrais acheter cette rolls royce
quelque chose comme ça adorable
avez-vous déjà fait votre volonté
bien sûr euh ii j'ai bien fait
ma première règle trois  il y a des années
et j'en
ai fait ma troisième
réécriture en octobre jacob comment
vous êtes-vous impliqué dans tout cela
euh eh bien il y a cinq ans
j'ai hérité de 50 livres d'un cousin éloigné
et mon père a investi cela dans gec pour
moi et je me suis intéressé parce que je
voulais  pour savoir ce que faisait mon argent
, puis plus tard, je pense que deux ans
plus tard, il m'a acheté d'autres actions
pour mon anniversaire et j'ai continué à
acheter et à vendre des actions à
intervalles réguliers depuis lors
et pourquoi êtes-vous intéressé
par de l'argent comme ça
bien je  'ai un  j'ai toujours été intéressé par l'
argent quand j'avais quatre ans je disais que je
voulais être avare
parce que l'argent est juste quelque chose que j'ai
toujours aimé et voulu avoir j'ai
toujours voulu être riche
[Musique]
quand il avait quatre ans
il était  intéressé par l'argent et cela lui semblait
tout à fait naturel
je pense
qu'il peut le gérer il peut gérer son propre
argent mieux que la plupart des jeunes de 20 ans 25
ans
mieux que beaucoup de gens n'en
sont jamais capables et je ne pense pas que ce
soit  les faire de toute façon
[Musique]
euh excusez-moi puis-je mettre cet argent sur
mon compte s'il vous plaît
euh puis-je aussi
encaisser
ce chèque
[Musique]
pourquoi portez-vous un badge aime maggie euh
parce que margaret thatcher est le meilleur
premier ministre de ce siècle et elle
devient  la grande-bretagne sort de la récession
elle réduit les besoins d'emprunt du secteur public
elle réduit l'inflation
elle réduit le chômage
elle s'assure que l'industrie augmente la
production et la productivité a
augmenté de 10 l'année dernière,
ce qui est incroyable car cela
ne va généralement que  en hausse d'un ou deux pour cent, ce qui
montre à quel point elle est un bon Premier ministre
et à quel point elle est bonne pour ce pays,
alors elle ne va pas faire demi-tour,
elle va s'en tenir à sa
politique monétariste et elle a tout à fait raison
qu'en pensez-vous  cette tête de colline
par le résultat des élections
honteux absolument honteux
absolument fidèle vous pensez que roy
jenkins n'aurait pas dû gagner bien sûr il
n'aurait pas dû gagner le conservateur
jerry melanie aurait dû gagner il était un
très bon candidat un thatcherite et
juste ce dont ce pays a besoin
oui  mais si euh je veux dire que le travailleur
aurait pu gagner
non, il n'avait aucune chance qu'il ait porté
une accusation, il n'avait aucune chance de ne pas avec
les minuscules virages de ce monde disant toutes
les ordures qu'il dit que
pensez-vous du  nationaliste écossais
eh bien il a perdu sa caution
pensez-vous que c'était une bonne chose
oui je l'ai fait je n'ai pas approuvé les
nationalistes écossais tout le
parti travailliste ou les démocrates centraux ou
n'importe qui sauf les conservateurs ou un  personne
mais les conservateurs oui
[Musique]
oui d'
accord merci
au revoir au revoir tu veux être comme
ton père
non pas vraiment je ne sais pas
pourquoi
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce que j'ai
mes propres ambitions et il avait ses
propres ambitions et si  nous voulions tous être les mêmes
les uns que les autres
euh si vous considérez la théorie de l'
évolution de darwin comme correcte
euh nous serions toujours des créatures unicellulaires euh
dans la mer et si vous remontez plus loin
que cela ne serait absolument rien
et c'est parce que  les gens ne font pas exactement
la même chose que les choses arrivent
si
mon père avait fait la même chose que son
père, il ne serait jamais devenu rédacteur en chef
de l'époque, il aurait juste été l'
écuyer d'un endroit dans le pays,
donc
je veux dire que les
gens doivent  faire des choses différentes et
vous ne pouvez pas faire exactement la même chose
que
vos parents je suis sûr que vous n'avez pas fait
la même chose que votre mère ou votre
père
avez-vous l'intention de vous marier et d'avoir des
enfants
euh non j'ai l'intention de rester un  célibataire euh
parce que je ne veux pas divorcer et
que la femme prenne tout mon argent
et cela semble se produire si souvent de
nos jours
que
je ne prendrai pas le risque
oui eh bien j'ai vu dans
le journal je pense que c'était au
Financial Times qu'ils envisageaient
d'introduire une taxe permanente sur les
banques  surtout pour les banques comme
elles en ont sur les compagnies pétrolières oui oui je
pense que cela pourrait être dommage
car le seul effet de cette taxe est de
diminuer les réserves de la banque,
ce
qui signifie finalement qu'elle ne sera peut-être pas aussi
capable de prêter que  cela devrait être le cas
et bien sûr l'industrie souffrirait
du manque de
ressources que la banque est en mesure de mettre
à sa disposition oui mais en attendant,
elle couperait um psbr,
ce qui signifierait que le gouvernement ne
prendrait pas autant de  les banques
et égaliseraient les choses un peu plus oui
combien de comptes bancaires avez-vous euh
j'en ai deux est barclays deux est lloyd's
un avec le national westminster
un avec les midlands et un avec
harrods et un autre avec euh
le  gouvernement ou quelque chose comme la poste
et êtes-vous millionnaire euh bien
euh si je changeais tout mon argent en lires je le
serais mais
malheureusement euh en livres sterling je ne le suis pas mais
j'espère être bientôt
que pensez-vous que
vous serez quand vous  être un adulte quel
genre de travail ferez-vous bien quand j'aurai
30 ans j'aimerais être le directeur général
de gec
et
j'espère que d'ici à 70 ans quand j'aurai 70 ans
j'aimerais devenir premier  ministre
pourquoi
pourquoi parce
qu'à cet âge tu peux avoir gagné tous tes
millions ou milliards
et tu as beaucoup d'argent
et tu auras du temps à consacrer à la
politique
[Musique]
que signifie le mot bonheur pour
toi
c'est très  difficile à dire euh
c'est très difficile de dire ce que
signifie le bonheur
comme l'argent me rend heureux si mes actions
se portent bien alors je suis très heureux mais
euh s'ils ne vont pas trop bien alors
je ne suis pas si heureux
je ne le fais pas  te connaître
[Musique]